قتلت شرطه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بالرصاص
شابا فلسطينيا من عرب الداخل بعد منتصف
ليله الماضيه في منطقه باب السلسله
بالبلده القديمه في القدس المحتله وقالت
مصادر الفلسطينيه الى الشهيد يدعى محمد
العصيبي من بلده حوره في النقب ويبلغ من
العمر سته وعشرين عاما وافاد شهور في
البلد القديمه بان افراد من قوه الاحتلال
اطلقت النار على الشاب بعد ان دخل في عراق
مع افراد من شرطه الاحتلال كانوا يعتدون
على فتاه بالضرب ويحاولون اعتقالها
واخراجها من باحات المسجد الاقصى
عائله الشهيد العصيبي قوات الاحتلال
باعدامه مشيره الى ان نجلها في العام
الاخير من الدراسه في كليه الطب وانه كان
في طريقه للاعتكاف في المسجد الاقصى
وقد حضرت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه من الصعيد
الاسرائيلي في المسجد الاقصى المبارك
وقالت لنا هدفه توتير الاجواء وجر الامور
الى مربع العنف في شهر رمضان المبارك وما
دعى المتحدث باسم حركه فتح منذر الحايك
كلما يستطيع من الفلسطينيين التوجه الى
المسجد الاقصى
والمرابطه فيه لحمايته ومن جهته قال نطق
باسم حركه حماس حازم قاسم انما حدث عند
احد ابواب الاقصى جزء من الحرب الدينيه
التي يشلها الاحتلال على الشعب الفلسطيني
وان الاحتلال يحاول الانتقام من اهل القدس
المحتله بعد الزحف الكبير الجماهير
الفلسطينيه في باحات الاقصى خلال صلاه
الجمعه